president biden is staying at camp david
this weekend he's meeting with his
national security team on the ukraine
crisis but there are major domestic
issues that have plunged the president's
approval rating to its lowest point
since he took office natalie brand is at
the white house to review mr biden's
first year in office and what's ahead
natalie good morning
good morning michelle president biden's
recent polling numbers have dipped under
the weight of the pandemic the economy a
spike in inflation challenges he
continues to face as he enters into a
key midterm elections year
just look at what we've accomplished
together so far now officially in his
second year in the white house president
biden touted one of his biggest wins to
date speaking friday before a conference
of the nation's mayors the
infrastructure law is a perfect example
of what we can achieve when we tackle
problems the way mayors do we came
together
democrats and republicans
and did something about it
but that bipartisanship was short-lived
and president biden's ambitious
legislative agenda has come to a
grinding halt facing pushback from even
some members of his own party they would
use the nuclear option to override a
rule that
we have used ourselves
but now seem to find unacceptable on
this vote on wednesday senate democrats
were two votes shy of changing
filibuster rules to allow voting rights
legislation to move forward
and with the president's massive social
spending and climate plan stalled he
acknowledged the bill likely won't pass
as is we're going to have to
probably
break it up the president says he will
ramp up efforts to take the case to the
american people he's ready to get out
there in the country and telling more of
the story of what we've accomplished but
also the work we have to date president
biden's tenure in office thus far has
been
pretty much as uneven as the stock
market george washington university
professor laura brown points to some
factors outside of the president's
control what really has i think
bedeviled president biden is a lack of
consistency and a lack of persistence on
the issues that americans care the most
about
which are namely the pandemic and the
economy
and president biden this week
acknowledged the continued frustration
among americans between covid fatigue
rising prices he said this week that
fixing the supply chain tops his short
list of priorities dana
all right natalie thank you